la parole et de notre collègue andré
trillard pour le groupe l'est
républicain
et ce pour deux minutes mais cher mon
cher collègue
merci monsieur le président ma question
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre la violence s'insinue
quotidiennement partout en france
il n'y a plus un jour sans que des
dégâts inacceptable ne soit commis sur
la voie publique des agressions
inadmissibles qui ont valu d'ailleurs
une hospitalisation en urgence à un
fonctionnaire de police à nantes les
casseurs à 10 du centre ville brûle des
voitures les commerçants sont et
terrorisé le go sport de la place de
bretagne a été entièrement dévaliser des
casseurs que l'on retrouve à paris vous
avez abandonné pendant cinq semaines la
place de la république à la pagaille une
violence dont vous êtes faits complices
sous couvert de bons sentiments
tout était pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes nous a répondu mardi
dernier le ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement
quel manque de lucidité la fatalité vous
ratera vous avez dû discrètement faire
évacuer la place de la république où
sous couvert de réinventer la démocratie
on a des pavés une place qui venait
d'être réaménagé à grands frais ou une
bouche de métro a été incendié avez-vous
pensé un instant ce que vivent la nuit
les riverains vous soumettez le
personnel de police et de gendarmerie de
situations difficiles et intenable ils
subissent avec ordre de ne pas
intervenir des insultes des crachats et
de la violence
leurs nerfs sont quotidiennement mis à
l'épreuve après des mois d'extrêmes
tensions liées à l'état d'urgence
les français attendent des protégés et
les fonctionnaires d'être dirigé l'état
n'a plus aucune autorité dans un pays où
le lac le lac 6 invite à toujours plus
de violence
quand allez-vous faire cesser cessé de
prêcher des bons sentiments pour prendre
la vraie mesure des choses quand
allez-vous rétablir l'autorité de l'état
merci pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur et pour deux minutes
monsieur le monsieur le sénateur je
crois que lorsqu'il ya des tensions dans
un pays qui peuvent conduire à des
violences extrêmes la responsabilité de
ceux qui porte une parole publique ces
deux convoqués avec la plus grande
rigueur la vérité pour ce qui concerne
d'abord les consignes qui ont été
données par mes soins à ceux qui sont en
charge du maintien de l'ordre c'est à
dire les policiers les gendarmes
elles l'ont été par télégramme à
plusieurs reprises avant les
manifestations j'ai rendu ces
télégrammes public
je les adresse ray pour ceux à venir aux
présidents des commissions des lois des
deux assemblées que 17 et g
d'abord il doit y avoir lorsqu'il ya des
casseurs des interpellations pour que
dans la plus grande sévérité
le droit passe il y avait monsieur le
sénateur depuis le début des
manifestations mille interpellations et
vous parliez des manifestations de
nantes de jeudi dernier
trente neuf personnes ont été
interpellées 24 gardés à vue quatre
personnes ont été condamnées à des
peines de prison dont des peines de
prison ferme
quatre personnes ont été mises en examen
une personne a été écrouée et les
procédures judiciaires se poursuivent
donc dire comme cela a été dit à
l'instant qu'il y a des consignes pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de fermeté
c'est une contre vérité car je viens de
rappeler très clairement ce que nous
avons fait la deuxième chose que je
voudrais dire le seul sénateur c'est
qu'on peut rendre hommage aux forces de
l'ordre
on va s'y lie à des interpellations et
s'il ya des interventions c'est parce
que les forces de l'ordre sont en
première ligne
et quand il y à des policiers qui sont
blessés par des pavés quand il ya des
policiers que j'ai été visités et qui
ont une fracture du crâne parce qu'il ya
des violences inacceptables
on ne fait pas des théories vaseuses
convoquant des contre vérités sur
l'autorité de l'état
on leur rend hommage en raison de
l'action qu'il conduit et ça c'est ma
responsabilité que de le faire enfin il
ya un troisième point sur lequel je
voudrais insister le seul sénateur c'est
que nous sommes dans un état de droit et
on peut dans un état de droit considéré
qu en contravention avec le droit on
peut interdire des manifestations mais
je vous rappelle quand même que le
conseil d'état comme le conseil
constitutionnel se sont prononcés dans
une décision le 16 février dernier qui
définit le cadre de droit qui préside
aux interdictions de manifestations et
je me rends conforme rigoureusement à ce
qu'il était du droit parce que c'est
cela être républicain quand on est
responsable
cette seconde monsieur alors cette
seconde je dirais une seule phrase vous
savez mieux que quiconque monsieur le
ministre qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie
dans le désordre merci